[Music]
the first ice skates were invented in
northern europe about a thousand years
ago
when people began lacing animal bones to
the soles of their boots to cross frozen
water in 1592 a scotsman invented an
iron skate blade
and before long the sport of speed
skating took off
these elite level racing skates are
produced by a small company co-founded
by a canadian speed skater a three-time
olympic medalist in short track
every single pair is custom made
after measuring a skater's feet a
technician applies layers of wet plaster
bandages
the same way one makes a cast for a
broken limb only here each foot cast is
comprised of two parts
[Music]
each cast serves as the first stage mold
for a skate boot
[Music]
the plaster bandages take five to ten
minutes to harden and dry at which point
the technician carefully removes the
mold one part at a time then reassembles
it with elastic bands
he surrounds the mold called a negative
with sand
he then pours liquid plaster into the
negative to produce a positive mold the
sand provides counter pressure so that
the plaster can't push the walls outward
and distort their shape
the plaster fully cures in an hour or
two at which point the negative mold can
come off
then the technician mixes up some
thicker plaster pigmented to make it
easily visible against the dried white
plaster
he applies it in select areas touching
up imperfections and tweaking the shape
of the mold
he files the toes and the rest of the
contour smooth producing the final shape
of the boot
he labels the finished mold with the
skater's name and puts it in the
storeroom until it's time to begin
constructing the skate boots
construction begins with boot lining
they staple a piece of genuine leather
to the mold pulling taut because any
wrinkles in the lining would irritate
the skater's foot next they glue on the
various structural pieces such as this
ankle padding it's made of memory foam
so it gradually forms to the skater's
ankle and holds the shape
the next step is the most technically
critical because it determines the angle
of the skate blade
they apply epoxy resin putty to the
front and back of the sole and adhere to
aluminum blade holders
then prop up the boot as the putty dries
over the next four hours or so
once the putty's hard they sand off the
excess to lighten the skate and round
out the remainder
then they begin constructing the outside
of the boot first they layer pieces of
carbon fiber a strong fabric commonly
used in high performance sports products
they tie the bottom piece around the
blade holders with strong thread
and bind the layers with spray adhesive
[Music]
next they slip a plastic bag over the
boot
[Music]
tie off the ends
and vacuum out the air
this tightly compresses the layers of
carbon fiber
now they inject resin a type of liquid
plastic and distribute it evenly
throughout the bag
the resin impregnates the carbon fiber
[Music]
after a couple of hours the resin dries
and hardens leaving the carbon fiber
boot stiff and durable
next they glue on the outside of the
boot made of vinyl
once the glue dries they remove the
plaster mold
and stitch the vinyl in place
they also take a vinyl lace cover sew
one side of it to the boot and attach
the other side with a hook and loop
fastener
that way it hinges open and closed for
lacing and unlacing the skate
the final step is to attach the inline
wheels or steel blades to the blade
holders
[Music]
you